[Musica]
sorprende fuoco tutto a tutti è tornati
solito stories
oggi nuova challenge prova non rimanere
soddisfatti challenge prima di iniziare
volevo dirvi due cose rapidamente in
rimaggio no la prima cosa è seduta su
qualcosa di diverso ho tagliato i
capelli
non so se sì se si vede bene comunque
grazie per i vostri consigli su
inizieremo innanzitutto non li ho
tagliati tantissimo vedete sono ancora
lunghi però ho tolto le doppie punte
sono rinati
ho fatto il ciuffo qua li ho fatti un po
scalati davanti vedete che cadono qua ho
chiesto consiglio appunto alla
parrucchiera su come farli in base al
mio viso e mi ha consigliato appunto
questo taglio in più gli ho detto che io
che volevo un po di volevo un po scalati
ma mi ha consigliato di non farli
scalati dietro per farli un po più pieni
vedete cosa ne pensate
scrivete nei commenti se secondo voi vi
stanno bene si stava meglio prima
sei bellissima allora la seconda cosa
che voglio dire è
bellissimo libro quanto bello contro
bello allora queste sono le date del
firma copie per il mio libro mi
raccomando sarà un'occasione unica per
incontrarmi perché non so appunto quando
torneremo in italia è sì ci sarà anche
vitali continuazione vivendo i vostri
commenti occupato se ci sarà oppure no
sì ci sarò non vedono l'ora di vedere te
non me e vitale comunque non vi
preoccupate se saremo entrambi è appunto
l'occasione un ricarico tracce non
mancate di doverlo di incontrarvi è il
mio libro è ora disponibile nelle
librerie e su amazon
se lo prendesse nella libreria in cui si
sarà in forma copie vi daranno un pass e
fare se la fila prima se lo avete già
preso su amazon nostra libreria non vi
preoccupate volete comunque partecipare
al firma copie però sarete dopo nella
fila quindi non vi preoccupate in ogni
caso non firmerò il libro non vi
preoccupate e ora siete pronti a ritroso
vivai allora sai di cosa si tratta
non provo a non rimanere soddisfatto ha
detto sì che cosa vuol dire secondo te
cibo prova non rimanete soddisfatto per
5 3 ma la bellissima gialla giornata
possiamo fare cominciamo prova non farti
venire fame challenge io ho già perso
per sempre fame in continuazione smette
di mangiare ha fame lo stesso è vero
fatemi sapere se anche voi
ma iniziamo con 161 bellissimi questo
slide
ma il franchise line house il nuovo
bellissimo
oddio con la scuola questo fabbricato
non so voi che effetto fa questo mi dà
fastidio che si sono days utilizzare
super ténéré addio sarà uno slide dentro
ma fanno metterle non lo so queste sono
altresì le tasche ceccardi ha iniziato a
diventare violento però aggiungendo un
milione di perline altri slime carta di
avere una sorta di ziegler
perché ti ho finito non compare su line
che figo il soufflè sly una forma di
fuochi il biscotto con il succo lo
mangerei subito il discorso col
cioccolato è già molto slime che strano
la un water cicli slime che sia un posto
verificato sopra questo
perché non bellissimo ma dischi
bellissimi questo lo trasforma in un
super cicli cura che bello ha messo un
per colorante in un super g clean
si e appreso uno slam normale ammesso
l'acqua calda immagino del colorante poi
lo scioglie dentro lori acqua bellissimo
questo li stessi e questo mi piace
ecco un water sigli wow che bello sembra
asqua questo ci piace
chiedesse scusa questo michael quanto
con il colorante ma si è votato no ah no
c'è lo slime dentro non la polla oddio
che disastro però era maestra non
particolarmente cabalista estera ed
eccolo si fa sotto al bello ma somiglia
sempre una sensazione strana sopra
vederli così gli iceberg che è bella
[Musica]
senza confronto fretta non so questo mi
fanno un po l'effetto pelle d'oca
tra le suore
no no no non mi piace non mi piace un
sacco bello ma un mouse è bellissimo
questo arrivo di nuovo al bambino
no ma ben terribile questo stato
bellissimo per 3 0 presunto boss casa in
versione micro polonio la slia bomba
fuori uno stranissimo
sempre che magari è la voce dello slang
che risucchia il microfono e perciò
vuole mangiare pure lui a bordo c'era
l'altro l'av adesso che bello bello
questo mi dà fastidio questo suono a me
dà fastidio cui vi piaciuti lo fossi un
prestito
no no ho fatto vinto un altro gp
[Applauso]
ma so stufa amano le custodie
dell'iphone sono stupendi con questi
colori
questo di spinaci sono stati incriminati
pirazzi effetti bisogna sapere sempre
presi in giro questi plan verdi un altro
[Applauso]
ma fa messo il colorante sopra vediamo
come diventa verde il colore guarderà
altrove lo faro blu scuro la fama non
sporcarsi le mani ma io penso che le
avevano sporchi e magari e quelle anno
la morte no non è bellissima cartella un
povero unicorno l'unicorno affettato
piatto destro scioglie fosse una candela
si no
l'on
verde sia 26 dentifricio un altro su
[Musica]
questa cosa ti sembra che mangiardi cosa
ci serve una fonduta di formaggio nella
sala nata a queste quando italiano le
saponette fa un sono utili bello che
erika bello senza l'arcobaleno contro
questo suppone temo che figata
molto bello
non capisco se acqua con la credo sia
slime è la saponetta quella viene
esclusa la spugna non ne frega proprio
solo acqua colorata
questo dolorosissimo ma adesso mi viene
il mal di testa
oddio ovviamente melo si è dato però in
trazione che play android pochissimi
amici quando taglia mela
ma questo livello perché hanno questi
dati ma sia bello poterne la bocca con
la mano e giusto l'effetto wow questo
bello un gol bellissimo salotto a cielo
di glitter e bellissimo
che cosa succede adesso prende fuoco
tutto questo è un arricciacapelli ed è
anche caldo molto caldo però pericolosa
questa cosa
tra di la scossa
oggi di quanto ok questo è un po strano
devo dire che un altro finita costatino
[Applauso]
errore nel camion di sottofondo peccato
ma inglese ma non lo sapeva arrivato qua
ecco un altro che scuote con un guanto
collettiva quanto sarà smiley poi
chiuderla tutto non mi piace il rock e
suoni questa sono zeppe di nuovo le voci
già terminato bello o maiolino che ora
in disperato il marito perché verrà
risucchiato dallo sly un po verminosa
normale al gallo bello ma l'effetto di
colori e zuppe
[Musica]
grossi bellissimo questo piace molto
orgoglioso
punto forte forte pigmento quel colore
anche se il verde per oscar bonotto e
bellissimo
bensì sordello però sto bene mattia quel
coltello cosa sembra un meno piave un
piatto signora
termino io penso che lavoro di napoli
così vediamo la ridiventati di bello e
di fare qualche colori spugna
la ripetizione questo con le uova non mi
piazzo
che bella questo effetto di colori ma
stato al pigmento pure questo questo sì
però quello sotto verebbe di arancione
giallo sfumato bellissimo ma allora era
successo fosse ricoperto io glielo
[Musica]
master di natale bello a questo momento
non ho mai visto con la carta argentata
bevendo
[Applauso]
forse se avesse chiaro ma insomma è
scappata ma pensionati con cipolla
trasforma di nuovo ancora si è il colore
è nuovo cisco metallizzato no perché
perché perché adesso shaun samsung
[Applauso]
stavamo sull'aereo che bello è proprio
il ghiaccio che core
c'è insomma incantato tipo di nero o il
colore nero color ciliegia rosa cosa ho
appena visto poi parte la musica e
sapone tasse ti senti allora ragazzi
avete vinto avete perso la sales noi
abbiamo straperso come tranne quelli con
la spugna che mi davano troppo fastidio
è vero come si è rimasti impressi 2
uno degli ultimi che abbiamo visto che
era tipo nero amaranto era quello
bellissimo e matura e bellissima mai
visto oppure tutti quelli arcobaleno
stupendi potesse sapere voi nei commenti
quale vi è piaciuto di più la stessa il
times stampo quindi il minuto 2.48
insomma scrivete il minuto e magari
quello che ho votato proveremo a
riprodurlo però a me fanno sempre troppo
ridere quelli che lo fanno super
velocizzato che sembra stare quando si
usano troppo ridere quelli là allora ora
vi lasciamo 4 castellini e su cui ticar
prove delle nostre altri challenge le
nostre altre versioni divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite
[Musica]